[Music]
i recently took a flight from los
angeles to new york and on that flight
there was a man sitting in front of me
i noticed that he wanted to get on early
you know they call people with
disabilities and children veterans
service members members as they should
and he kept trying to come on and i kept
seeing the woman at the gate say to him
we're not ready for people who aren't
service members he clearly wasn't a
service member or a child or someone
with a disability he seemed kind of like
bent out of shape and he was sitting in
front of me on the plane and i noticed
the sweet flight attendant shout out
chris
at jetblue he went to gently wake him up
i mean it was like as gentle as i've
seen
like the way you'd wake up like a baby
do it to me pretend like this like hey
yes your food's here oh thank you very
much okay that's the normal reaction
here's what the guy did
what what is going on what are you doing
oh i'm i'm sorry sorry your food's here
i just wanted oh my god you know what no
i don't want it now okay just put it
down you know you woke me up in
hysterics you were hysterical
i'm hearing this whole thing i took my
headphones off because it was like
fascinating did you get involved well a
little bit because chris later the
flight attendant said he was very nice
when i went to the bathroom he said are
you the guy in the you know and i said
yes and i said i i got to tell you
you're so patient he couldn't have done
it better and i was thinking what would
i have done
you know how would i have gotten through
this it requires a level of patience you
might have had to meditate i might have
had to i would have definitely had to
and i wonder if chris does meditation
but i want to say thanks to chris and
everyone at jetblue
other than that it was a wonderful
flight i'm glad you made it back so am i
so we could do the show that's the only
reason that's the only reason
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life short and i am
your host
uh justin wong back on the ground life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
back on the east coast east coast and
connecticut i'm so excited for the with
christian my brother hi we're also on
the east coast yeah well in the same
room yeah same coast same room yep same
uh breathing the same air you haven't
had covered yet have you
oh since the since the og i got so
offended for a second you did yeah i was
i was like one of your the originals
yeah but but you haven't had any of the
later strains no
no because i um i'm very careful why i
was careful do you get offended when
people suggest that you weren't careful
no because it's
so hard to be as careful as you need to
be
omicron careful requires like a bubble i
think you have to be in a bubble
i don't know i haven't gotten it i'm
very careful yeah well i think i also
got it on a plane anyway who cares why
did you ask me that well i don't know i
was wearing the same we're breathing the
same areas
but um we're in the east coast the east
coast is beautiful remember we have to
talk to the microphone oh yeah i was
looking out the window yeah see the
beauty
i'm gonna shout out the east coast
someone no you could nature you could
just position your microphone facing
outside
you know why i can't because i need this
chair these creaky chairs i needed to
back up against the wall so it doesn't
move we've never gotten the chair fixed
which is a theme yes uh which hopefully
people don't mind we've only been doing
this show for three years yeah coming up
on three years wow um but we're over
three years now yes again who cares
uh it's a lot of who cares so far why
are we talking about why because it's a
it's a big terrors episode
episode because we have a guest that is
incredibly impressive and uh everything
he says you'll care about so we thought
we'd we'd pat it with a little bit of
who cares at the at the top
um because our guest today is well and
speaking of that my need for meditation
on the plane and how flight attendant
chris probably had to meditate and if he
didn't he maybe want to check out 10
app or any of this guess our guests
great work in the field of um meditation
he is a buddhist
uh behavioral therapist psychotherapist
psychotherapist
uh he which is an interesting
combination that we're going to get into
he's one of the leading people in his
field and he's just an extraordinary
mind and i was so excited to talk to him
our guest today is
dr mark epstein he's written several
best-selling books about the subject and
very practical
books the one that i read was called
going to pieces without falling apart
and um it's about how to uh improve your
life how to get by with all of this
because we're all burdened by
we all got a lot of [ __ ] as i was once
told
by someone very close to me we all have
it we all have shits and um he helps
people kind of figure out their [ __ ] of
course clean off their [ __ ] if you will
yes yeah clean the [ __ ] off their the
shoes of their psyche hmm very well you
should write a book no why
i hope he's not listening to this but um
he'll put it in slightly more eloquent
terms i think
uh so here he is let's get right into it
please well we're not getting right into
it
there is a lot of [ __ ] before this
you can't take credit for getting right
into it
that ship has sailed that's that's a
good part you can't labor the point and
dance around and then take credit for
you what do you say we just jump in
yeah why are we just beating around the
bush here let's get right into it um so
but let's do it without further ado um
the the brilliant and fascinating and a
person that you will care about what
they say
dr mark epstein
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello against your booming but
we'll meet again
[Music]
mark you you'll appreciate this i have
this app called 10
the temperature i was just i was telling
michelle dan encouraged me to uh
to do the interview with you he told me
that he did oh yeah
oh great okay so i was wondering when
that was gonna pay off
um i've talked to him about how much
that app has really helped me and but i
was unable to do it was joseph goldstein
your
mentor i believe um dr goldstein um it
was finding equanimity was that was the
subject for today and i was not able to
complete the meditation because i was
rushing and um as i want to do for
people who are unfamiliar
with um with all of this with what you
do and buddhism in general
can you explain why
it is so important to find equanimity
what what that means to you and in your
practice i think equanimity is like the
um
it's the highest
uh achievement
in the non-achieving uh buddhist
hierarchy you know
because
meditation comes in to help people with
an untrained mind
and to help people who are being
buffeted about by their emotional life
or by their thoughts
um you know by their by their anxieties
or their fears or
or their obsessive thinking or their
attempts to control life you know that
things that can't be controlled so
meditation is like working against
all of those tendencies the metaphor
they use is like a fish flapping on dry
ground you know that's what i always
related to about my own mind what makes
you flap you you mark what makes you
flap the most what is your most
reactive experience i was always a big
worrier
uh when i was uh when i was young you
know so
i think that set me up for the for the
meditation because i know you're also i
mean people might be surprised to learn
that you're both you can be both a
psychotherapist and
a buddhist how did you combine those two
i know that's a very that's a huge
question and you go into great detail in
your book going to pieces without
falling apart is there's the new one
we're going to talk about the zen of
therapy but um in going to pieces uh
without falling apart you you talk about
the the contradiction between
psychotherapy and or at least our you
know the traditional sense of it um it
being about him
empowering the self and building up the
self yeah um whereas obviously with
meditation buddhism it's it's
disempowering the self disempowering yes
yes
yeah
the the word you use what is it it's not
unintegrating it's well it's not being
integrated or or disintegrated but to be
to be able to be unintegrated the way
the way one is when
listening to music or
after sex or before you're going to
sleep or when you're playing basketball
or uh you know i found that fascinating
at the after sex part especially the way
you describe the um it's the comfort of
being with somebody without the
attachment of people without needing
anything from them in that immediate
moment yes because it's in the aftermath
of the of the desire and the need and
the attempt of satisfaction so so then
you're just there together so that
that's analogous to um to the equanimity
that you were asking about or to what
meditation
uh can can possibly do you also talk
about how love is that how it is the act
of being holy yourself and being present
with in the company of somebody else in
the presence of somebody else i thought
that was a really
the way you you articulate what it means
to be in love to be to be in that state
of bliss i thought was really um it's
beautiful but it's also
something that i of course everyone
aspires to how have you found the best
way to achieve that again a very broad
question i know but
to achieve that kind of happiness that
kind of presence well i didn't answer
your last question so i i could try to
answer the last question about earlier
um the thing about combining meditation
or mindfulness or buddhism with being a
psychotherapist
i had the weird experience you know i
ended up going to medical school and
becoming a psychiatrist and whatnot but
uh but i had the
sort of strange experience of
being immersed in buddhism and learning
about meditation and everything
before i knew very much about anything
else so i was still you know 19 20 years
old still in college when i found all
this how did you come to that how did
you discover um
my my first uh my first week in college
i met a girl who i was interested in who
was taking an introduction to world
religion class
it's always the way it's not always the
way no it's very idiosyncratic how these
things happen
um and it never occurred to me to take
any kind of religion class it was i was
like happy to be free of religion
uh but but i followed her into the class
and the the the first semester was
eastern religion eastern thought
uh
uh hinduism taoism and buddhism and
those texts
like really touched something in me
especially the buddhist stuff
so i started reading more and pursuing
it and there were other courses that you
know a psychology courses that i was
interested in that were like
cross-cultural that had a bit of
buddhist uh stuff coming in so it's not
controversial in your in that field in
the traditional it was very underground
you know this is uh when i was in
college it was the early 70s and there
but it was the late 60s early 70s so the
the counterculture was seeping into
the university you know and uh one a
couple of the graduate student teaching
fellows because where i went to harvard
where the professors don't really teach
the undergraduates just the the graduate
students do most of the teaching one of
the graduate students was a guy named
daniel goleman
who
ended up becoming the psychology writer
for the times and then he wrote
emotional intelligence but in in those
days he was um you know
six or seven years older than i was in a
graduate student in psychology who had
been to india already and he was already
interested in meditation and
i walked into the classroom where he was
teaching the section of a
psychophysiology class and he in those
days he had long curly hair and he was
wearing purple bell purple bell bottom
pants and i was like oh this guy he's
got something that i want um
yeah it was in addition to the purple no
it was mostly about the outfit but yeah
but then you know i liked his mind also
so i made friends with him
and
and he said oh if you want to learn more
uh you should meet these people who who
were already his friends joseph
goldstein and jack cornfield and ramdas
wow for
those names to me are excited yeah to
people who are into meditation and i'm
and i'm very new to it um those are big
names that's like saying like oh i'm
into basketball i'd love to meet kareem
abdul-jabbar and larry michael jordan
for jordan exactly exactly so they were
they weren't quite as
impressive as those guys but uh
but so i went out to um
a boulder in in the summer where they
were all teaching and i'm and i met them
all and started taking classes with them
and started doing retreats with them
so i went as deep as i could into the
meditation can you describe the benefit
that you noticed in your behavior and in
your mind
as i mentioned already i was sort of an
anxious type and
worrying and i knew i was pretty unsure
of myself like sort of post adolescent
questions of who am i and where and what
not and i had tried to see a therapist
when i was in school i had gone to the
health services to
confess some of my anxieties and
the
uh psychoanalyst who met with me for a
couple of times said oh yeah your
problems aren't that difficult it's
basically you've you've you're suffering
from uh from an edible complex and i
don't know what i didn't know what that
was i was very unsophisticated
but i was glad it had a name but i still
felt this something about wanting to
make love to my mother no it's not that
it's like competition with the family
more but yeah
you know my father was a professor of
medicine and wanted me to be a doctor
and i was resistant i think it was more
more about that but we could talk about
that later if you want
yeah okay good no we have plenty of time
and by the way this is live oh good no
i'm kidding i'm kidding no
uh but then that when i met the
meditation teachers instead of like
uh looking to analyze what the source of
my anxieties were they were like why
don't you stop all that and just
settle into your body you know one try
to watch your breath try to watch your
mind why don't you just try to be with
yourself as you are
rather than trying to figure out turn
that off yeah well it's just like like
the
thing
meditation doesn't really turn off
thinking that's that's a sort of
misunderstanding
because what the mind does is think
but um but you identify the thoughts is
that you you don't have to be uh
captured by the thoughts you don't have
to be totally
identified with the thoughts and there's
more to the mind and the body there's
more to the person
than just what what or how they're
thinking so the meditation like showed
me that started to show me that oh
there's something else i'm not just who
i think i am you you know like i so that
experience of actually that must have
felt radical it felt it so radical
enough that i was hooked on the like
like i wanted to know more
from that angle
yeah you're it's also there's no it kind
of alleviates a lot of the shame too so
because because like you said you're not
being told to turn that off or you're
leaning into it if anything right i mean
like
what is that and i'm curious about that
i can hear joseph goldstein's voice
saying noting no you know any kind of
feeling or thought that comes up you
don't avoid it you don't run from it
that i found really transformative the
non-judgmental aspect of meditation
that's one of the things that links it
with psychotherapy you know that's how
later on when i decided to become a
therapist how does one
act as a therapist you know like what
makes what makes a therapist a therapist
that's a good question yeah
i know even freud had trouble uh with
that question
he gave instructions to
his
acolytes to his disciples on how to be
the right kind of psychoanalyst but but
it was very hard for people to
to do what freud recommended which was
suspend judgment and give impartial
attention to everything there is to
observe i learned how to do that through
meditation so then when i read freud i
was like i know how to do this oh yes
i've been trying to do this for years
you know wow yeah i i love the idea that
therapy you talk about can be considered
you say this a two-person meditation
i love imagining that that flow that
evenness that the presence the dual
presence with somebody else is um
is is so interesting i i and i wonder
what freud himself would have thought
about the teachings of the buddha there
they reached out to me from the freud
museum in london
uh
which is uh the house that freud moved
to when he left vienna in 1940 and that
where his daughter and her best friend
live after he died and they've turned it
into a museum and they're doing a show
there now called freud in china
because at the end of his life he
collected these little chinese uh
collectibles that he kept on his desk
and they asked me they said they've
never done anything about psychoanalysis
and buddhism uh wow so they're they're
having a show and they want to have a
discussion about the relationship of
buddhism to psychoanalysis i think by
the end of his life freud would have
been open to it you know he sort of
found his way into his own kind of
meditation by doing a lot of cocaine and
yes you know it's another entry way yeah
he did right people might might be
surprised to learn that he did i mean as
robin williams said in goodwill hunting
he did enough cocaine to kill a small
horse dan harris you're talking about
yes dan harris anthroid um two great
minds by the way let's let's link them
in a positive way
two very influential people um but what
what what was his so he was using
cocaine to stimulate his mind in order
to yeah in order to in order to uh he
was watching his mind freud you know
that's his great interpretation of
dreams his he was watching his own mind
he was analyzing his own dreams he was
making use of this peculiar quality that
we all have which is you know we're both
thinking the thoughts but also
aware
of ourselves thinking the thoughts you
know like we have the self-reflective
capacity that uh psychoanalysis makes
use of and meditation makes use of that
must have been a huge concentration when
you are going through your schooling um
freud must have been obviously that is
uh is is that was when you were studying
was that considered the uh the person to
study he was sort of the tail end of
people
trying to make freud have the answer to
everything
um so we didn't really study
undergraduate psychology we didn't
really read freud and medical school we
certainly didn't read freud and and
then when i was training as a
psychiatrist i had some very good
psychoanalytic freudian types who
supervised me when i started to see
patients but the
the psychopharmacologists were already
on the ascendant in the field of
psychiatry by the by the time i was uh
coming up because it's a wrap about the
drugs it's all about the drugs yeah i
talked to michael pollan about that on
the show but it's but um
it's
was that discouraging to see i mean to
see the rise in the psychopharmacology
uh world and and as you're getting more
in touch with um buddhism and
mindfulness and seeing the benefits
they're in it was discouraging to see
people trying to make the drugs answer
all the problems the same way they had
tried to make freudian psychoanalysis
answer all the problems the same way now
people are trying to make mindfulness or
meditation or buddhism or
psilocybin or ayahuasca answer all the
problems you know people are people are
always looking for the quick fix and the
one thing and
so uh
i was impressed that some people
[Music]
who were suffering from depression or
anxiety or bipolar illness or or
whatever
really needed the drugs and that the
drugs really worked
and that was like a godsend when the
drugs really worked and then i was also
impressed with how
one dimensional a lot of the
psychiatrists were that they you know as
i was saying before that they wanted
a drug and a catch-all problem yeah
so but it was a good time for bringing
mindfulness or buddhism into the field
because people were discouraged about
psychoanalysis but still looking for
inspiration in terms of
how can
being together be healing you know so
you didn't meet any resistance from your
community mark i i i have this
resistance to you know when i tell
people even um i suggest well meditation
has really improved so that i find
there's a slight bit bit of
embarrassment still i just grew up with
it being
kind of more
hippy-dippy you know woo-woo kind of i
did feel that you did
yeah when i was i was i moved from
boston where i had
gone to school and done my internship to
new york
to do my psychiatric training
and the
the person who was running the program
that i was going to be training at was a
a very fierce very well-known fierce
psychoanalyst named otto kernberg
and uh a friend of mine in boston who
was actually a sufi psychiatrist uh and
he knew the field and he said when you
go to that program you better watch out
because if otto kernberg hears that
you're into this meditation stuff he's
going to eat you alive quote unquote
no literally he was cannibal as well
yeah as well as being a fierce
psychoanalyst
um
so i very diligently kept my buddhist
thing uh quiet while i was there and i
trained for three years and i had otto
kurnberg as a supervisor one-on-one
and um
and we liked each other and then they
offered me a job uh for
in after i finished my training and i
worked there as a uh you know staff
psychiatrist for a year and i decided
okay they've offered me a job i can
start to talk about what i'm really an
accident i can come out of the media
quote-unquote classic yeah and then it
turned out all all the other
psychiatrists they were totally
interested like it was i was projecting
all this stuff you were telling yourself
a story
yeah one guy was already leading a group
therapy at the uh um uh uh the yonkers
zen center like they were all interested
the field was ready you know did you
admit that you had been did they laugh
when you said you had had this reticence
yeah yeah yeah that's funny yeah they're
like oh we knew you were sort of into
this well it's it's it's odd it's also
like a perfect example of of how
beneficial mindfulness can be you talk
about and joseph goldstein of course the
stories that you tell yourself you know
the the what that fear is is simply um
stories and um
uh i'm curious about your attachment to
fear too and and that's that's a good um
i guess example of it that yes well
there are the fews are infinite yeah you
just replace one with the election with
another okay yeah
[Music]
we love our plus cbd i love it love it
they're delicious and they work more
importantly i mean that's what you
really want you they could taste like
anything really as long as they work but
these happen to both work and taste
delicious especially if you're having
trouble sleeping people struggle with
sleep and if you're listening to this
and you think i struggle with sleep you
might want to try these even if you're
not used to trying cbd it's a good
introduction to cbd and then if you get
used to the cbd and you're into it it's
a good introduction to thc oh they've
become a
very regular part of my routine and i
enjoy them so much the plus cbd sleep
gummies really get me the rest i need
and i always wake up feeling focused and
refreshed never groggy and always ready
for the next day they're really great
yeah you don't wake up feeling like
you've taken some sleep medicine no you
just it helps it always helps me stay
asleep too yeah me too which i've
noticed and they're all natural they're
all delicious raspberry gummies they're
made with award-winning cbd along with
melatonin magnolia bark and lemon balm
for powerful sleep support and it's the
it's san diego's trusted cbd brand plus
cbd and it's the number one selling hemp
extract in the u.s
um and then the calm gummies are perfect
for just daily relaxation i take them
during the day if you want to try them
yourself which we both highly recommend
you do uh you shop now at pluscbdoil.com
and you enter the promo code long long
for 40 off your order 40 no brainer yeah
this episode is sponsored by ritual we
have a new ritual here on the show
our ritual is talking about protein
powders oh i like how you did that yeah
and um they can be intimidating they are
to me too yeah because there's so many
so many and have you been to one of
those uh gnc or one of those stores you
know vitamins first of all they're in
big intimidating tubs and they're made
with like lightning bolts on the cover
and there's always like a really
muscular kind it's like i don't know i
want to be that
but but here's the reality even though
they're even though the whole topic is
intimidating we need it yes we need
protein it's it and it's not just about
muscles it supports bone health it helps
keep you sated that's right and as we go
through life protein needs change it
sure does so it's important to choose a
mix for different stages my protein
needs are different than they were in
college i needed protein to like be
muscular i wanted to be like a little
meat head but now that you're a
middle-aged man you have different needs
yes so rituals essential protein is a
delicious
plant-based protein powder with three
distinct formulas designed to meet the
body's changing protein needs so you can
choose from three thoughtful formulas
with 20 grams of pea protein the daily
shake 18 plus which is a complete amino
acid profile featuring choline an
essential nutrient and common dietary
gap and then there's the daily shake 50
plus which i'm on my way to needing
that adds calcium hmb
to the mix helping to build and maintain
muscle mass for healthy active aging i
like the idea that you just add a little
water you shake it and you drink it yeah
it sounds so easy i know even even
putting it in a blender which is how i
make money you have to clean the blender
no ready to shake up your protein ritual
i am our listeners get 10 off during
your first three months at ritual.com
long ritual even offers a money-back
guarantee if you're not 100
in love visit ritual.com
long today for 10 off your first three
months
[Music]
did he encourage that your your
synthesis of
uh um meditation
um kernberg
kernberg was an expert in what was then
being called the borderline personality
disorder
so it was like a lot of um
uh young patients with very
apparently very emotional overwhelmed by
their own the intensity of their own
feelings who often complained of feeling
empty on the inside and they would like
starve themselves or cut themselves or
they had trouble with it with anger and
so on
and so i was very interested kernberg
wrote a lot about psychological
emptiness
and
emptiness is one of the big concepts in
buddhism
so so i was trying to figure out in
those days is the buddhist emptiness the
same emptiness that kernberg is writing
about that these patients are
complaining about buddhist aspire to
emptiness i talked to him about we had
good interesting conversations about
that and he was very helpful
as a supervisor helping me
help my patients
with the intensity of their anger or
rage or aggression you know how to how
to how to own that but not be destroyed
by it there was a big movement in the
years after i was describing with
kernberg
there was a big movement in the field
that became known as dialectical
behavioral therapy dbt
and the the woman who founded that was a
woman named marsha linehan who it turned
out had buddhist training and she was
also a behaviorist
and her big insight was that these
people who were diagnosed with
borderline personality disorder who
seemed so hyper emotional that they were
actually phobic towards their own
emotions
they were they were they were full of
feeling but they didn't know what the
feelings were
so
so she made like flash cards that said
you know mad sad glad and and like
introduced like this is what it feels
like to be mad this is what it feels
like to be sad and so gradually and that
was a kind of adaptation of mindfulness
of meditation where she would gradually
to yeah to note the actual physical
sensations of the feeling and to realize
that you can be with those feelings
without immediately rushing to act on
them
so that's and that goes back to the
equanimity thing that you were asking
about at the beginning so that's a sort
of movement toward equanimity through
self-awareness not being reactive that's
that's served me or i'm i'm seeing the
benefits of that um i often find it
played out on the on the road when i'm
driving especially i'm in la right now
and so you know driving in a place like
that i had somebody
swerve into my lane moments like that
it's hard for me to not be
reactive i can feel
my body changing i can feel
the anger
how do you suppress not suppress it i
know that you let it go you you process
it but um how do you deal with those
moments of
of reactivity and how do you make
synthesize them in a healthier way so
that's interesting what you started to
say you know the almost the freudian
slip of how do you suppress it yes even
though you know that
so
but that but it's interesting because
that is how we all think like if we
could just suppress it and so that's
creating a tension right there because
instinctively either we're gonna act out
on it or we're gonna try to suppress it
the thing about a moment like that
or any intense emotional or trauma
related you know is that the impulses
the emotional
impulses run on nerve fibers that are
faster than thought
there is a point in there
after your body has already reacted and
you can feel the rage where you become
self-aware enough
to be able to stay with the feeling of
arousal
without either
suppressing or acting out and that's
interesting the danger in suppressing
too and not to labor the point but that
it that it it remains that it somehow
remains and and comes out um
it looks direct
yeah that's i think one of the big
dangers of trying to suppress like like
the discovery and buddhist meditation
is that
things
self-liberate
if you give them the right attention
so that there's a little bit of lingo
involved in talking about about it this
way but
um
like an emotion like anger
uh
if you can
hold it in in the larger sense of the
word holding if you can hold anger the
way a mother
holds a a distressed baby then anger
loses a lot of its power over you
you know because what is it really it's
it's uh it's thought and feeling oh it's
great you know it's just sensation it's
sensation either physical or mental
so if you can put a big enough
uh frame around it
you know which the mind the observing
mind is capable of doing then anger
itself just becomes bits and pieces more
phenomena
you know that can contribute to your own
awakening that's what the buddhists
would say i know we're jumping around
mark but speaking of the babies that
you've sparked a memory of from one of
your books i i'd love that and you talk
about the state of being silent with a
child you talk about your friend who was
worried that
he was being somehow false when he spoke
to his his daughter his young daughters
with a baby voice you know and i and i
find myself when i'm around kids there
are there are times i'm curious about
being a father i'd love to be one day um
my experience with kids is that
sometimes i run out of things to say or
there's a moment of silence and i found
that really uh enlightening what you say
about that um if you can touch on that a
little bit the the idea of being uh
encouraging a child's sense of discovery
those moments when you run out of things
to say though those are the creative
moments right right
that's like the prelude to to a creative
something because that when that happens
in psychotherapy you know people come
when i was in therapy let's i can talk
about it that way when i was the patient
i would always hope that i was going to
have a dream the night before because
then i could bring the dream oh yes and
then i didn't have to deal with my own
anxiety about starting like what am i
going to say and what what you know
so people often come to therapy with a
sort of prepared list of what i'm going
to talk about and that's all fine but
usually the
what arises spontaneously
you know in the awkwardness and the
anxiety of the silence you know of the
room two people sitting not quite
knowing what what they're doing there
together or what will happen next that's
a much more direct route in
to whatever is bringing the person to
therapy in the first place
so
as a therapist i've had to learn
how
to how to wait
you know and not not rush in and try to
make it happen for somebody fill the
space
as a meditator i've had to learn how to
wait and and not
not be
rushing to try to find the
the peaceful state of mind that once i
felt in meditation that i'm trying to
get again you know like like that you
know not not chasing the uh the feeling
i've had to really learn you know
and and that's it's not like i've
mastered that well you find yourself
doing it and then now i can only hear
joseph's voice goldstein's voice begin
again and begin again and go back to the
breath is that i mean
yeah i had a good uh i was on retreat
once and and i was describing to the
person leading the retreat what that i
was sort of chasing this feeling that
i'd had on the last retreat and i
remember he said something like
don't chase her let her find you
and and he gendered it like that yes
and i thought i thought oh this guy
really understands me yeah
he knows what brought me to buddhism in
the first place exactly it's
the sort of erotic thing in meditation
yeah well but it does help to
contextualize it it does help to kind of
like put it into a practical perspective
um people unfamiliar with with the
practice might
might think this is um
a strange way to talk about meditation
but there are times when as you well
know better than anyone it can be
transformative and i mean it can be very
rare times i mean mostly meditation it's
so ordinary you're just like you know
it's boring because your mind is boring
yeah but you figure out that your boring
mind is actually interesting
and it's it's it's hard work because
you're you have to sit still
and just be with you know yourself
i think you said this it's a great quote
and i want to read it for people uh i i
don't want to falsely attribute it to
you but i'm pretty sure meditation and
psychotherapy each encourage a
willingness to face life's difficulties
with courage that can otherwise be hard
to muster
um yeah that sounds like me yeah i'm
gonna give it to you um i find myself
really wanting to i resist those moments
of silence because i become aware then
of the the expense of it it's this
professional's time it's my time it's
it's the timely expense but it's also
financially i think oh man the longer i
sit here this is like a good every
minute you want to you want to get your
money's worth yes it is flying by as we
speak um
how do you encourage your patients to
take a more present approach i guess
well i just think it's amazing that i
get paid at all
[Music]
so it all surprises me that people come
back
oh really that they find it valuable
well what is it do you think i mean in
your because you've been on both sides
um what is it about therapy for people
listening to this who are maybe a little
resistant to it um what is the value in
it and what do you think those what do
you think keeps people coming back i i
think it's precisely
uh
it's precisely its lack of value
that uh you know
well it's it's like it's an anomaly and
yeah
yeah you know it's so weird that it
exists like where did it come from you
know
um like freud you know um it's true
what was there before freud i mean what
was closest to that were there versions
of therapists i don't know confession
yeah i guess so yeah
but fraud wasn't going to confession
like the prescription was always you
know ten hail marys and five are fathers
i don't know it's like you know i mean
philosophy has existed uh
there was philosophy before freud yeah
but psychotherapy you know you were
making reference to the this most recent
book of mine
and the the the subtitle of that book
it was uh you know uncovering a hidden
kindness in life
so i so i think there might be something
about kindness
that um that therapy
makes room for and that that that people
are in need of you know and respond to
uh and make and make use of as being
just an essential
human truth as being a um
as being a sort of neglected human truth
you know like we're all we're we're so
aware of the um of the badness of the
cruelty we're so aware of the cruelty in
the world right all of us you know in
our in our culture in the world you know
uh and then the media feasts on it and
we're all scared because of it and and
you know to sort of um
flip it for an hour a week you know
where
where kindness is uh actually the uh the
engine that's driving this world much
more than the cruelty yeah do you find
that your your patients are influenced
by what's going on in the world i mean
are people absorbing all of this stuff
of course yeah yeah of course of course
come on we're coming
uh coming from all these years of covid
and now and and then and all the years
of trump and
uh and now the war in ukraine no it
everyone is very attuned to the outside
world of course of course and at the
same time uh uh people are living their
own individual lives and and those their
own individual lives are full of drama
and tension and fear and and you know
the entire range of the human experience
are being played out by each of us
that that's sort of what i wanted to
show in the in the book where i was
you know taking
individual
sessions individual psychotherapy
sessions and writing about what the
actual
session was like you know you do it for
a year right
for a year yeah random patients but just
to show how ordinary the discussion is
but also how even in the in one grain of
sand you can see the whole universe kind
of thing you know get like one person's
struggle with their with their spouse
all of our struggles are being portrayed
[Music]
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hey parents this one's for you wundery's
kids and family podcast little stories
everywhere transports your family to an
imaginative world with enchanting
stories and exciting adventures in each
episode hosts virginia madsen and robbie
damond read an original children's tale
if you've been looking for screen free
entertainment for your kids little
stories everywhere encourages your
little ones to use their imaginations in
one of their latest tales you'll hear
about mark the unicorn he's just like
any other unicorn except he doesn't have
a horn that makes him an easy target for
school bullies that is
until he runs into the most popular
unicorn in school sprinkles and their
unexpected adventure changes his life
forever listen to little stories
everywhere on amazon music apple
podcasts or listen early and ad free by
joining wandery plus kids in apple
podcasts or wondering plus in the
wondery app
hello
[Music]
we heard you on npr not too long ago um
talking about death it was it was really
fascinating how you were describing it
because obviously it's a thing that was
a thing that i've thought about uh since
i was little but um and struggle with
but i had never heard it
said in such a
such an art such an accessible way
talked about in such an accessible way
how you you describe the feeling that we
have at any point in life of ourselves
because i think the interviewer would
ask you what do you think happens after
death um and you detail a conversation
you had with your father um that was
yeah it was in the context of it wasn't
really about after death because who
knows none of us know what happens after
death but it but it was about dying
um
which also none of us really know about
but uh except for you but we ca
except for me yeah i'm the i'm the
current expert no that's right it was
the act
yeah yeah i had this one conversation
with my father
who was a scientist and a you know a
materialist we would say didn't believe
in anything
you know afterlife or a spiritual
whatever he was you know a physician and
a scientist and and we had never talked
about anything you know buddhist
meditation he was like okay
but he uh he ended up with a brain tumor
like the the john mccain
ted kennedy
malignant brain tumor
and it had already spread by the time
they found it and he and and it was in
the non-dominant side of his brain
mostly so his thinking was still intact
he knew he was going to die from it you
know and he had to stop seeing patients
because he had a brain tumor you know
he'd been working up until he was he was
84. wow
wow um but but i realized oh i've never
really tried to talk to him about what
uh what maybe i understand you know
about what what i imagined from the
meditation you know about dying and to
give him comfort or i mean was it in an
effort to i didn't think about it as
comfort no i thought about it as like
giving him the meditative technology
since he was going to go through this
process of dying and what if they're
right and this is actually helpful and i
have
out of my own uh
inhibition
kept myself from talking to my own
father about it you know so i screwed up
my courage and uh and called him and
said you know like we've never talked
about this i don't know if you're
interested but you want to know what the
buddhists say about dying
but i couldn't use any spiritual
language because he would be dismissive
of that so i had to really put it into
my own words the way i framed it was
you know that feeling that you have deep
inside that hasn't really changed from
when you were 20 or 40 or 60 or 80
you're still you but how do you know
that you're you what is that feeling
really if you try to put your finger on
the feeling it's a kind of invisible
thing you you know like you can't like
you know it's there how would you
articulate that yeah yeah it's just
invisible you know so so i said but uh
what the buddhists seem to suggest is
that if you can learn to relax your mind
into that invisible feeling
where you are who you've always been
that that you can ride that feeling out
you know in death as the body
shuts down that
that kind of invisible
feeling of of you is is
i think becomes more and more infinite
would be one other way of saying it i
didn't say that i didn't say that to him
but
uh and and he was very you know he he he
was like oh okay you know
thanks a lot he took it in
do you think it did impart any comfort
do you think it did i hope so yeah yeah
comfort i don't know i hope it i
you know what the like if you read the
tibetan book of the dead for instance
which was like the the classic tibet
it's actually uh it's it's actual title
is something like uh the
the
guide to
um
oh how does it go it's like the guide to
being in the between
something like that uh but anyway it's
like a classic how-to like that you were
supposed to read it to the person as
they're dying yeah it's like the
beetlejuice handbook yeah exactly the
guide to the recently
it's it's it's teaching you
where how to how to put your mind into
that into neutral while all this stuff
is happening so not to go not to go to
the fear uh but
the same way when you are in the car and
the guy's cutting you off not to go to
the rage well right stay in that place
well i think that's the challenge and
death you know
yes mark i think about it now in a new
through a new lens i see it through the
different lenses in the context now
being the the ultimate because
meditation obviously is about letting go
and the moment with the guy is letting
go it's it's i guess the ultimate
for version of that of letting go right
yeah
i bristle it letting go always a little
bit um i said it like three times you
well well people think meditation is
letting go and maybe maybe that's
the right right way to think about it
but um letting go has for me it has a
little bit of that suppression thing
uh-huh yeah let it go too it's like
being with yeah yeah being with rather
than letting go like how can we how can
we be with whatever is happening you
know okay even in death did you find
that that conversation with your father
um comforted you i mean did it bring you
yes yeah yeah i'm very uh relieved uh uh
that we were able to have that
conversation i think there was a moment
of closeness there
at least for me you know you know when i
think about death of course i think
about the my loved ones dying and i and
i my fear is that there will be
real resistance to it and with myself i
i fear that's what i'm resistance to
death yes
rage against the dying yeah um well that
was my father's favorite uh poem no rage
against the doctor oh really he could he
would yeah my father could uh
uh
say that whole poem you know is that
dylan thomas
he would know i think it is oh okay but
i don't want to say uh yeah i'm not if
i'm not sure
i'll be um
okay people expect that from me
but people imagine that with meditation
you're no longer afraid of dying i don't
believe that what meditation helps you
do is not
indulge the feelings that are there it's
not going to change it's not going to
change like why wouldn't death be scary
you know it's the ultimate unknown but
but i but i always think we were all we
all managed to be born uh-huh and which
and none of us can remember that right
imagine what that was i know i know we
could get through if we can get through
being born i figured i could get through
dying that's true
that's how i've that's how i comfort
myself really yeah do you still think
about it do you do you ever find
yourself all the time yeah
all the time no really no problem i'm
sorry i brought it up then do you do you
believe in reincarnation mark i i find
that i do yeah yeah what does that look
like to you because i always think of it
from this laurel and hardy movie flying
deuces where a hardy after he dies in a
plane crash she turns into a horse
and laurel comes upon so so i saw that
was a formative movie for me because i
was watching it when i was you know five
or six and struggling with these things
and um and so i still think of
reincarnation that way which i'm sure
is probably an offensive way to think
about it uh that you just turn into an
animal
i i don't know that movie oh well it's a
it's a real timely reference the young
listeners are going to love it it's
the 1938 or 37
it's a great it's really funny though it
still holds up flying dudes yes the
practicality of of how any of it happens
like from my
scientific mind it doesn't make any
sense
i don't really have a picture of it it's
more a feeling
that
sort of surprises me that i that it's so
easy for me to
uh to accept
but the idea is that
this body
this incarnation this personality is a
temporary
consolidation
you know of some kind of truer
spirit that is you that that goes to the
kind of invisible
thing that i was trying to describe to
my father so that it's a a temporary
encasing of something that you know we
all know the body's temporary when that
drops away like um
uh one of my uh one of my teachers
around all this i mentioned at the
beginning was was ramdas who was a
you know a harvard psychologist richard
albert who teamed up with timothy leary
around lsd and all that but then then he
went to india and he had a real
uh a real guru a real teacher who
let him feel the the unconditional love
that that the
proverbial guru is sometimes able to let
you feel but anyway the story of that
guru is that when he
was approaching he had a heart attack on
a train
just before he died and he had one one
assistant with him on the train and they
got him off the train to go to the
hospital and he knew
that that he was close to death and he
his words to his assistant were uh i'm
being released from central jail um
[Music]
so the body this is this personality
this incarnation is like being in
central jail you know for the spirit
central jail you know in india
so it must have been a relief to him
i think it was wow
wow
a great relationship he was but he was
an awakened being you know
yeah
we're all afraid to get out of jail i
know i am yes of course that's we kind
of like this jail
wow in the way fight against it i i
that's interesting considering i was
just thinking about how you you you talk
about the dalai lama saying that
all human beings uh seek happiness and
and um
that if that is true i wonder how how do
you reconcile that that that the
enlightenment that this guy came to know
he attributed to it was like a jail to
him i i that's um i bet i can maybe that
made him happy what the dalai lama he
not only does he say that all human
beings seek happiness but he also says
that all human beings have within them
the seed of the happiness that they are
already seeking
you know right important so it exists so
that's how you bring those two things
together so the the
the guru
was totally aware
of the happiness that that existed
within him that was being constrained or
confined by the aging heart attack body
you know that what that had become
central jail
so he was being he was being released
into the ocean you know that the seed of
which was already the drop of which was
already in them i aspire to that kind of
death i guess we all youtube yeah it's
in you too it's in youtube yeah it's it
is
thank you for that um
we have a quick uh lightning round if
you don't mind sure whatever that is
okay
okay
and forgive me for some of some of these
are
kind of like embarrassingly basic
questions like this one
what is your
boy what is your favorite emoji dr mark
epstein one of the great
psychological
i don't know anything about emojis okay
uh you never use them in texting with
your kids no
never once used that's actually
impressive
no i'm sure i've used them but not
enough to have a favor to have a
favorite
okay
who was your oh boy who was your first
celebrity crush uh as a young child in
the latest oh that's easy annette
funacillo oh okay sure the mickey mouse
club
yeah or one of her movies she did like
no the mickey mouse club that was how my
mother enticed me to leave nursery
school uh when she would come to pick me
up that the the mickey mouse club was
gonna be on oh really yeah
it's also having so much fun
that's funny it's also how you got into
buddhism um yes
yes what is your uh the promise of a
netflix what is your favorite ice cream
flavor uh mint chocolate chip yes okay
some uh as is ben stiller you and ben
stiller have uh similar appearances
yes oh have you been watching severance
oh
so good
so good i i am always a therapist so
boring at first but then getting better
it took a while yeah it takes a while it
was so patient i i miss
[ __ ] movies like that and content like
that you know
that require a little bit of patience um
what is your favorite holiday
purim
you're our eighth purim you no okay it's
the first one um because of the
hamantaschen what now what is humantason
it's a pastry a poppy seed uh or prune
or apricot filled pastry oh is it a
little like arugula um no it's from the
same cultural
uh place as rubella but it's but it's
it's uh different from rogue oh i'm in
touch uh what is an acclaimed movie
you're embarrassed to admit that you
haven't seen that people maybe kind of
shame you for you haven't seen
huh um
i've seen most things
like your daughter would shame you for
like dad how could you not have seen i
haven't seen best in show oh okay great
so you'll love claimed well i mean no i
won't love it but no no why why do you
think i'm not a fan of that's why i
haven't seen it but
okay well that's a good excuse to not
have seen it yes um okay
okay
what uh what is a game show pastor
president that you'd want to be a
contestant on uh what's my line oh that
yeah that's it was that groucho marx
hosted uh
i think for a while yeah um maybe not uh
well do you and do i see you're drinking
something
or the newlywed game oh yes how do you
think you would do with your wouldn't
that be i always
i feared that i would not i would do
terribly yeah and then she would say
well don't you know me right yeah yeah
it would only lead to but i like that
show yeah me too um
do you drink coffee or tea uh and if so
how do you how do you take it mostly
coffee these days yeah uh with milk with
milk okay uh if you could learn another
language what would it be uh uh italian
maybe now oh oh okay just just wanting
to travel there and wanting to universe
yeah what is uh what is your favorite
cereal if you uh still eat cereal
granola yes okay if you had to choose a
different first name there's nothing
wrong with mark obviously nice sturdy
name but if you had to choose a
different one what would it be
i don't know
okay
if you had a sandwich named after you
what would be on it the mark the dr mark
epstein's sandwich
what would it be comprised of avocado
smoked salmon
tomato
and
maybe some goat cheese and lettuce oh
yeah man what kind of bread are we
putting it on uh some kind of good bread
yeah whole grain bread whole grain um
and what is your favorite tom hanks
movie
i have no idea
and are you you um would you rather take
a time machine to the past or the future
uh the past
is there a particular era you'd like to
explore back to the time of the buddha
maybe oh yeah yeah sitting under that
would be interesting yeah
um are you a night or a morning person
um
both um and are you more of a talker or
a texter do you prefer texting or
talking to friends these days texting
yeah yeah and and this is kind of our
final one um if you would indulge us uh
if you could finish this sentence dr
mark epstein life is short so
enjoy it yes well
i got have i enjoyed this and i've
enjoyed your work so much i truly it's
um i i love reading reading your books
and um i cannot wait to get into the
xenotherapy
um we will again talk all about it but i
i just thank you so much for your time
you're totally welcome it was completely
fun
yeah um
i think a lot of therapists have that
yes yeah therapist vibes yeah
god what a fascinating guy yes and
although an interesting intersection of
figures in history buddha and freud well
i know his book gets into obviously more
detail than we did about that but there
are some very when you start digging
there's some real obvious
intersectionality
to those two schools of thought but the
glaring one that we talked about is that
freud was about the eye it was the
examination of the ego the ego yeah and
um you were like what happened before
like what came before freud and he was
like well
i guess there was philosophy before
freud and i pictured our father
being like yeah they're
freud what came before freud my son well
at least i have two sons that i'm proud
of
i thought you did a you handled yourself
quite well no for talking to a stranger
who happens to be incredibly intelligent
and measured i thought you did a nice
job oh thanks eventually it
at certain points the lightning round
got a little well yeah it like ventured
into like in our more much more
articulate version of the chris farley
show sometimes where you like i love
this about you and i like and you like
read a passage that he had written he
was like yeah i wrote that yeah and but
you didn't really have a quite a
question to follow up with you're like i
just love this passage there's like so
many notes really because it's one of
those books that you read that you want
to highlight and then the next page
you do it again and then the next page
you do it again and it's like then you
start thinking i'm never gonna go back
and i know it gave me a kind of a
different perspective
on meditation one the way he said that
it's not about
turning off thoughts it's more about not
letting them hold you captive exploring
them yeah that's what i've because i've
always thought of meditation more as the
former you know like how do you turn
your brain off no no so just so you'll
get more into this when when i almost
said if you do the 10
app um but joseph goldstein whom he
mentions that's like a mentor of his i
can hear him saying you have to lean
into those thoughts you have to like be
a little bit more
i guess clinical like curious about the
thoughts i always like when an expert on
something
talks about the thing he's an expert on
but also claims that it's not a cure-all
for things you know like i like that he
you know talked about the good things in
terms of meditation how could help but
that's not the thing that will fix
people or take care of every problem you
need to find the right balance in your
life whether it's
you know taking the right kind of drug
or the right kind of therapy or
meditation that's why i
religion is something that is can be i
know stifling to me because it's like
religion tells you this is the thing
this is this is the thing to believe in
that will take care of i've been
watching a lot of like youtube videos
lately and um there are a lot of ads for
these really like muscular guys these
rip guys were like do you want to get in
shape like this used to be me and it's a
guy like pushing out his gut and he's
like but now there's a way to actually
take control of your hub and you think
he's going to say something like
i don't know eat vegetables or something
about probiotics or he's like a pill and
it's some
fat burning and it's like
right away those guys like just reek of
of uh phoniness it's like it's like
cultish it's cultish it's like snake oil
salesman yeah you can see how people
have been tricked by that from since the
beginning of right and that's why on the
other end of the spectrum someone like
mark epstein who is a legitimate expert
on on this topic has humility about and
but recognizes that it's not a cure-all
right you're right there's i'm drawn to
that yeah so now i'm not being drawn to
people who have humility about what
they're pushing
i've never been drawn
more to meditation because i know you've
been talking about a lot but it's a
little different
now hearing from an actual expert
harvard educated forget harvard yeah
it's experience yeah
you're new at this yeah so this is a man
who's been doing
it for decades i also appreciate how he
said his honesty about how he said he
got into it it was basically a girl yeah
girl i didn't know he said he had an
edible complex and
like you i thought i associate edible
complexes much more with sleeping with
your
mother well maybe that's you should
explore that why i think that yeah no
it's not because i have one right
because like i've always thought about
it
sure sure yeah
but uh but he said no it's usually much
more about just competition with your
father yeah but i think edible complexes
have been skewed but i'm remembering now
better that the story of oedipus rex
that his father did play a big part his
father started
exactly yeah it's a big it's a big part
of the story so he kills his father
right yeah so so the complex
all
sorry
so the complex shouldn't just be about
sleeping with your mother but i think
you know maybe people latch on to that
because it's
the most
like uh upsetting scandalous facet of an
edible complexion
right it's like the it's the it's the
juiciest yes it's it's not a good way
yeah juicy in a bad way i assume yeah
that's what you see in the worst way
yeah is there a term for that like a
really good juicy no i think juicy tends
to be good is there bad juicy um hmm
that's a good question that's a juicy
question isn't juicy good though it's
like okay to say something juicy fruit
something delicious oh man this drink is
it or this food is so delicious so juicy
and gross now i'm picturing other things
and you say juicy can be really gross
yeah really juice juicy a juicy fart ew
gross
juicy oh dr mark epstein's i love this i
think juicy's it tends to be a positive
attitude i think so point is the part of
the edible complex that deals with
sleeping yeah with your mother that's
why it's because it's not juicy but
there there's a juice
i don't think it's juicy
yeah there should be a word for it
though yeah but why does stuff like that
intrigue people why does steph to your
earlier point like why does why did that
happen to become the most popular part
of the oedipus story because it is like
because it's salacious fallacious
salacious okay yeah oh we got it he
really liked the lightning round yeah
see now
yeah
he was really into that he he loved it
um
yes he clearly was i think he wanted to
go with that if you had to change your
name
from mark to something else what would
you i don't know
i know what about what is what's your
favorite tom hanks movie no idea yeah he
was done
yeah but he answered the ones he knew
but he's honest this is the thing i
liked about it yes
when he didn't know or didn't care about
an answer he didn't hem and haw and
trying to think of the right way to say
he doesn't i don't know but he knew
right away which made me more
self-conscious because i could tell he
was his brain was doing and you know
like an audit of the question and it was
determined to be
completely uh irrelevant but see i think
you
shouldn't be necessarily focusing on the
question being bad or him not caring
about the way he answers i think it's
more about he he doesn't have an answer
for it some of them he did it's not
small talk you're not at a cocktail
party chit-chatting with that that
exposes the way we both see that
lightning run where to me it's more
conversation it's more kind of like
loose and uh informal and conversational
but
that that's that was probably a
difficult pivot for some people to make
uh yeah he also may have interpreted the
lightning round in a more literal way
light like a fast like i need to be
efficient with my answers here because
you called it really shouldn't be called
a lightning round it's true um true so
if he doesn't have an answer for
what name he might want other than mark
then i don't know you know
that's true he's not just like think uh
how about
frederick he's not gonna just like make
something up if he doesn't have an
opinion about it he's an academic
his ver first name he had a good one for
no i think he didn't know you know i
don't know
because he well because also
why just think of something if he yeah i
think academics are more into like if
something is true well and you say it
and like what we were saying earlier
he's very aware of his thoughts he's
very in touch with what he's thinking
and feeling and and so if something
didn't come to mind if he was asked to
like
recall something or bring something to
mind and nothing came and you're right
lightning round wow that's a good
defensive
i'm a big markup scene apologist yeah
yeah he's a fascinating guy he's
fascinating really smart i want to i
want to get into his stuff i know we
should he's written i don't want you to
tell me to do it i want him to tell me
to do it
let's read a letter say everyone should
all right julie weeks richard
uh this is from julie weeks for charm
subject florida misses you dear justin
and christian we
[Music]
i i finally decided it was time to write
after listening to every single episode
in order and then you having our beloved
patrick wilson on i live in the st pete
clearwater tampa area ah and you are
correct we love that family
yeah julie i didn't need you telling me
but it's just one other voice to the
chorus of patrick of wilson wilson
lovers yeah
i started listening to life for short in
mid-2020 when i was working all by
myself in a huge warehouse for eight
hours a day whoa you guys definitely
kept me company and distracted me from
the weird noises coming from the unit
next door where we later found out a man
was actually living oh my god that's
wild i know about that i'm the same age
as justin so i enjoy all the 90s
references i also love your selection of
guests ah that's great i would have a
hard time picking a favorite but i do
really love patrick wilson and hands
down my favorite actress in the world is
melanie linski ours too ah there's two
yeah oh man she posted a really cute
thing for mother's day i saw that i'm a
little distraught that you filmed lady
of the manor in saint pete and you two
and melanie were all there and i didn't
run into you it's probably a good thing
though because i would have come off a
little crazed and starstruck as i am
also a long time brandon st randy fan oh
my god thank you
thank you anyway just wanted to thank
you for being a friend during some of
the darkest days of my adult life well
well
i'm so glad we were there in that
warehouse i've been trying to think of a
good would you rathers and keep coming
back to florida things great if you had
to be turned into okay if you had to be
turned into an animal walrus style my
husband and i absolutely loved that
movie by the way
so i know what type of person she is
when people say they love that movie i i
and i like those people a lot um
not just because i'm proud of the movie
walrus yes yeah evolvers yes uh would
you rather so here we go would you
rather be a manatee or an alligator
would you rather have your face okay
then there's a separate would you rather
be a manatee or an alligator um i'd
rather be an alligator manatees are so
yeah big right i do not want to be a
manatee i because yes and they're also
so vulnerable to so many things they
just kind of float i know alligators are
too but
they just kind of
float around and drift around yeah
people fee they fart constantly really
yeah um they eat mostly cabbage and let
they eat greens
but alligators i wouldn't mind that part
alligators you have to eat like they
still look like manatees yeah but don't
focus on the superficial i know but i am
superficial the alligators um are apex
apex predators and so they get to like
have the run of the place and yeah but
they have to eat disgusting things like
that it wouldn't be disgusting to uh to
well it's your brain inside right now
right you're right yeah i oh oh in that
case manatee you don't get a manatee oh
in that case definitely manatee
yes alligator you have to eat like
little baby deer maybe just get used to
it you i would
you'd have to survive i i i wouldn't
want to fish you justin as a manatee
would survive maybe a day
uh but justin as an alligator you would
you would figure out how to make it a
few months i think our friend our
neighbor mick and linda they have a
manatee at their place in naples who
just kind of floats around the um little
canal okay so you would move to
maples and be a manatee on the canals
there you changed my mind i i didn't
realize i had a human brain okay um and
then
uh would you rather have your face
attacked by mosquitoes or have your feet
attacked by fire ants
oh god that's awful um
i would rather have my feet attacked by
fire ants i care more about my face than
my feet
can you imagine the sound just the sound
of the mosquito
this is the chorus of awful
fire ants
we used to watch that kings of pain show
yeah it would hurt it would hurt and it
would hurt
adam and caveman yeah it would
definitely hurt more than the mosquitoes
i think
yes but uh i think you would just go
into
i think i'd do the fire ants on the feet
because it would hurt so badly but after
the initial
uh attack i think after the initial how
long does it say how long they do it oh
she said this would occur for a whole
minute every time you left your home oh
for the [ __ ]
wait can you wear shoes
i doubt it
i doubt it every time you lift your home
and then if you wear a protective thing
i'd wear a pee keeper of course
you know the mask
wait but when she says they attack your
face to
are they successful or can you scamper
away
or they're just going for your face i
think you have to suffer through it for
a whole minute or can you dodge them for
a minute i'm picturing you running i
know you are
both are funny picturing you like
running away from fire ants the
mosquitoes is funny because fire ends
you just like high step it yeah that's
funny too yeah um um if you can't defend
yourself then yeah i would pick the um
i guess i'd pick the ants yeah
i i was awful yeah it's awful um
that that's a would you rather from a
tusk fan yes you know um that's and then
back to julie that's all i've got if you
come back to tampa bay area i've got
some i've got some great dive bar
recommendation
including one that does questionable
karaoke every single night questionable
karaoke i like the series about that
yeah my husband and i would love to hang
out and talk about dodgeball walrus
galaxy west etcetera and lady of the
manor and how it was filming down here
thanks friends julie
and julie richard and it's pronounced oh
she says it she knows how he
pronunciation julie
she does that phonetically re re charm
rich harm richard um thank you julie
what a rich charming yes that's a really
good letter um and i miss tampa maybe
miss tampa i know i know i love that
area well uh our sample friends are
coming back north for the summer so
that'll be nice to
get back to
naples
friends sorry yeah um anyway uh we're
rushing a little bit because we got
something to do yeah two minutes anyway
thank you so much jesus you should
always rush i know i should pretend i
have something to do uh and thank you so
much to the esteemed dr mark epstein
right and if you guys would like to
write into the show our email address is
life is short at wandery.com yes and we
will talk to you next week
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian
slowing down making me anxious also
produced by megan v monaco and katie b
allen and uh senior producers michelle
miesh lance audio engineer sergio
enriquez executive producer marshall
louis he's on a hike shout out to dave
our new uh cohort over at the company
wondering wandery
bye
[Music]
oh man i feel
she's like
she's
she's like that sucks she doesn't want
to be on camera she's covering her face
no she did make the choice
i know yeah i know she just seems like
i know her
and now she doesn't have to marry that
guy yeah in the long
[Music]
what is this
oh yeah i knew i knew her
[Music]
oh god what the hell was that panicking
music oh my god it feels so old
don't you feel old
can you imagine wanting to watch an hour
happen oh my god i think that was i'm
like i know i feel like i'm on adderall
holy [ __ ] if you like our show please
give us a five star rating and a review
and be sure to tell your friends the
next episode will be out in a week but
you can listen to it right now ad free
by joining wandery plus in the wondery
app you can follow this show on amazon
music apple podcast and the wondery app
or wherever you're listening right now
in the episode notes you'll find some
links and offers from our sponsors
please support them another way you can
show support for the show is by filling
out a survey at wonder.com
so thank you for supporting
you